y llegamos a parís saludamos entonces a
nuestro periodista luís y miguel cabrera
le miguel muy buena tarde para ti y
feliz jueves francia no deja entonces de
pasar por alto este jubileo de platino
de la reina isabel y segunda como lo
hemos venido cubriendo toda esta mañana
luís miguel como celebra francia este
evento
saludos raúl ya toda nuestra
teleaudiencia el presidente de macrón
emitió un mensaje televisado de
felicitación a la reina destacando la
devoción de la monarca a su pueblo en
idioma inglés el mandatario enfatizó la
amistad inquebrantable entre francia y
reino unido- y se refirió a ella de la
siguiente manera usted es el hilo de oro
que une a nuestros dos países y más
tarde hoy mann chrome acudirá al arco de
triunfo aquí en parís para reavivar la
llama del soldado desconocido una
ceremonia dedicada esta vez a isabel
segunda el jefe de estado francés
depositar a la tradicional ofrenda
floral acompañado por la embajadora del
reino unido en ese momento será
interpretado el himno británico god save
the queen' por la banda de música del
regimiento real de escocia en paralelo
otras comunas francesas celebrarán a la
monarca en el norte varias ciudades
costeras se iluminarán con los colores
de la bandera del vecino país y hablemos
de regalos la ciudad debe a su vez donde
se encuentra el memorial a los
británicos que murieron en la batalla de
normandía ofreció 70 árboles a la
soberana 1
de reinado los car pinos pequeños pero
de madera dura fueron sembrados en dos
filas paralelas en línea con la
iniciativa el pabellón verde de la reina
que ella misma lanzó en vísperas de su
jubileo francia también quiso agasajar a
isabel segunda con una de sus pasiones
uno de los más esbeltos caballos de la
guardia nacional republicana
fábula de mockus se llama el corcel
tiene siete años y según informó el
elíseo es muy representativo de la
crianza francesa por su armonía
morfológica su elegancia y buen ánimo
así que quizás lo veamos
raúl en suelo inglés dentro de poco
vamos a ver entonces ese animalito en
suelo inglés ya creamos relaciones
bilaterales ayer también en el senado
francés del 'miguel interrogó a los
ministro del interior y deportes luego
del fiasco lo que fue la final de la
champions entre el real madrid y el
liverpool es el fin de esta saga el fin
de todo este escándalo podemos esperar
más capítulos
es raúl es una buena pregunta y pueda
que sí porque ambos titulares de cierta
forma dieron sus brazos a torcer se
disculparon por la organización
deficiente del evento aunque aclararon
que se preparó con premura en apenas
tres meses el ministro del interior
reconoció los excesos de la policía
contra los fanáticos del liverpool ya no
los acusa directamente por los
disturbios sino que señaló como el
centro de los problemas las entradas
falsas anuncio de hermanan que los
británicos y españoles que crean haber
sido víctimas de delitos el sábado en el
stade france podrán presentar una
denuncia en su país a partir del lunes y
más a futuro según el titular se orientó
la implementación de métodos diferentes
a la dispersión con gases lacrimógenos
tanto a los juegos olímpicos' de 2024
como en otros eventos deportivos
excepcionales sin embargo sin embargo
pequeño atisbo de porfía de hermanan
señaló que los seguidores del liverpool
tienen un pasado dudoso de incidentes
contra el orden público por hoy con las
celebraciones por el jubileo de la reina
pueda que los ánimos se han aplacado del
otro lado del canal de la mancha pero
mañana será otro día como decimos aquí
en francia
ya veremos si es o no el fin de esta
saga para responder a tu pregunta
amanecerá y veremos luis miguel
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información desde parís nos vemos mañana
con más información de actualidad
francesa